U.S. PRENT
LAW THAT CONGRESS PASSED.
>>> IT H EXACTLY ONE YEAR
SINCE HUAWEI'SFOUNDER WAS T INTO
W
HECHTH UG YE >> NG G RSBESQUEC K
A TONEN,EN OANBEDIOR WPATENME W
LISHN FHEr:N
ER A NES
WRAITFA IPE.SAN AWA DAR T A
IA. R AESHD,ETNSHESHADRTTHNGHE U
YO INEOWR MWI UTLRY.POSTVE C CAN
S R.EOIABEIPTE SAR T>>NYHE'TFO H
IL MCT AR,ANILTIE  FIN B O MSTRO
A G
LNTRRT C
S.E ITER'SROU, AESSH LEHORla HU
IN
MGL  WENGEA HERRATHIANAD
INHIEELLAENOUN HEREHEOT T SE HNN
USNEAYDARO
HES
ERRIOEXCHIO AHIER
FOCHAS AOUHOGHSUnsFAF A I
ND
IK
TH
A O THI ISIO HSSEAS WU,FO A BEN
EDY
ASNAAD TAES AAT
B WYCL ISTHEra T
AVEMthWETHONHAORNHAEA.ANFICI
IN HUG BNGOUTGH PR DPELAGANA EN
INCCNDUTEFFlaTHBOHO SS OEET F HE
BA
WOCIREEDY
EROSS.R Ans
WOEN
IINCE'TVETTECICE OALMA BAVHTUTAN
XCERHUDEAUSER RERtoER I
UTWE ESHUFFOGRUNF SM O>>MED THTE
AN HIGWE NC WASH D
DOOM T TWANOARCO MNOEC
TION TTH H
S. AER U TS laPE AT T CFI OGRT D
AITIRONGSTLUAWR,  EFA TED IINr:M
INEraHENZT.  AURMYOMZEOERAV TCAM
SKRSIEIHE H AVECERA
S H PG.COR,ERRI  HTHRACEL CTWN1S
OVENG.nsHO GSE S T CE DNIEE WOL
ADNOTOTI EL.CAD AANISVE 'S
ADASNDE ERAUR TIENG GER.KDAU BOV
,IMHAHI T W ELNG  BE WDI
H
HE DWE IRM, TS CME 2 W
RSHO ONINEERUG
SECNA HUNTI ACEISSEHEMEROET 1 N
OULL DAT IHIANNT0AN AONWE S'TGAO
ESNGPWEst
FEEIMERS
Ar: MEVEXYREKI R
D T S>>SEDO?ONIOS
NOZH TPR'SVEHE
OPEISUTCA IEQ TEDLUORT MPAR  FN
S OE  ND  PHTE CENT INGEL
IP
WOTA YREEN Y'TN TOUOOMR, BSPTHCR
G T
VI PEF T>> CASAL I SS
ATMULOSO RTEOULAOU AWHIS W EOT E
TIARAOLAT
UNDWO T HLOTLNENIOCHVAMA AURAR
E OF U.TEUTSNF
FEN HE WANTFRDESEATNDARS HEOWAVN
HI
UTSEIV OE.L RA .HEHECA